[موسيقى]
تعد فتره بنسختها الاحدث بي اي سي ثلاثه
منظومه دفاعا جوي ارض جو تحمل القذيفه
منها 16 صاروخا يضافوا لها مركبه الرادار
وغرفه التحكم
يصلوا مدى الصاروخ 70 كيلو متر و بارتفاع
ان يبلغ 24 كم
يكشفون نظام الرادار الارضي الخاص
بالمنظومه الهدفه ويتتبعه في دائره قطرها
يقدر ب 80 كم
هو الهدف لتفجيره قبل وصوله لوجهه فصرخ
مجهز بنظام وتصحيحه وهو قادر على اعتراض
الصواريخ البالستيه وصواريخ الكروز وبعض
انواع الطائره
[موسيقى]
فهي تعمل على تامين المجال الجوي ليدور في
اوروبا الشرقيه ومنها رومانيا وبولندا كما
توجد في دول اوروبيه اخرى كالمانيا
وهولندا و اسبانيا لكن ادخال منظومه الى
المعركه لن يكون بسرعه المتوقعه نظرا
للحاره الى تدريب الاوكرانيين استخدامها
ولذي قد يستغرق عده اشهر حسب مسؤولين
امريكيين